if a thing is happening and then someone
comes out and says I believe thing
happening is the result of a person
wanting it to happen they say yeah
you're a conspiracy theorist but you
then come out and be like I got no idea
why but things happening and well is
that a conspiracy no I never said
anybody who's doing a purpose like like
population reduction how about this how
about we're seeing across the around the
world countries are seeing their
populations decline you've got people in
the United States sterilizing their kids
aborting their kids or just outright
advocating not to have kids with climate
change
it's happening climate reduction I'm
sorry um population reduction is
literally happening now the question is
can you prove an individual or
individuals have been implementing these
policies with the intentions
specifically of reducing population well
the answer there is yes not all of it
I'm not saying every single instance of
every single uh active that reduces
population I'm saying Bill Gates goes on
stage and says we have to reduce
population so the funny thing is this is
a conspiracy theory